>> THIS IS AN INFLECTION POINT
AND YOU ARE EXACTLY RIGHT.
YOU PUT IT IN PERSPECTIVE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
>> ROBERT AKIL IS A ATTORNEY AND
ACTIVISTS.
THANKS FOR COMING ON.
IF PROGRESSIVE ACTIVISTS HAVE A
RIGHT TO INTIMIDATE AND SCREAM
AT PEOPLE THEY DISAGREE WITH
POLITICALLY AND PUBLIC
RESTAURANTS AND IN FRONT OF
THEIR HOMES, WHAT ARE THE
BOUNDARIES OF THAT?
AND WHAT ARE THE BOUNDARIES NOW
IN THE NEW ACTIVISTS OF THE
LEFT?
>> WE ARE TALKING ABOUT THE
FIRST AMENDMENT RIGHTS.
WHAT MAXINE WATERS SAID TO HER
SUPPORTERS IS, EXERCISING HER
FREEDOM OF SPEECH.
IT'S A SWAMP TERRITORY IN D.C.
RIGHT NOW, WHERE THEY ONLY
LISTEN TO LOBBYISTS AND SPECIAL
INTEREST GROUPS.
>> IT'S A LITTLE STUNNING FOR ME
TO TAKE OUT A LECTURE FROM
ANYONE ON THE LEFT WHO HAS BEEN
WORKING OVERTIME THE PAST COUPLE
OF YEARS.
AND IT'S A DEBATE ABOUT WHETHER
IT IS APPROPRIATE TO SCREAM AT
PEOPLE IN PUBLIC, AND TO FORCE
THEM OUT OF, FOR EXAMPLE,
RESTAURANTS.
THIS IS NOT AN ATTEMPT TO WIN
THEM OVER OR SO THAN THE OTHER
SIDE OF THE ISSUE, IT'S AN
EFFORT TO INTIMIDATE THEM.
YOU CAN'T READ IT ANY OTHER WAY.
YOU CAN'T TELL ME THEY WERE
TRYING TO INFORM SARAH HUCKABEE
>> BECAUSE MEMBERS OF THE
REGULAR PRESS BRIEFINGS, THEY
DON'T GO OUT AND HAVE TOWN HALL
MEETINGS, THIS IS THE ONLY TIME
THE INDIVIDUALS HAVE THE
OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK WITH THEM.
IT'S BEEN >> Tucker: WAIT,
TRUMP JUST PREEMPTED OUR SHOW
YESTERDAY -- >> THEY DON'T SPEAK
IN A TOWN HALL.
OPPONENTS.
I'M GLAD THAT YOU ARE HERE, WE
DISAGREE.
I THINK WE SHOULD HAVE A
CONVERSATION.
HE DID NOT HAVE THE RIGHT TO
SCREAM AT ME IN FRONT OF MY
CHILDREN AT A RESTAURANT.
IT'S AROUND MY HOUSE ON A
WEEKEND.
COME TO SOCCER GAMES, GO TO MY
PARENTS FUNERALS.
DO YOU SEE THE DIFFERENCE
BETWEEN HAVING A DEBATE OVER THE
ISSUES AND INTIMIDATING PEOPLE
IN THE PUBLIC SPACE?
>> THIS IS PART OF THE
ADMINISTRATION.
RIGHT NOW IT'S EXPLAINING WHAT
THE POLICIES ARE WENT BY
EXPLAINING WHAT'S HAPPENING TO
THESE CHILDREN.
IF THEY WANT TO HAVE A
CONVERSATION ABOUT THIS, I DO
LIKE OTHER ADMINISTRATIONS HAVE
DONE AND DO TOWN HALLS AROUND
THE COUNTRY.
DON'T SIMPLY HIDE BEHIND THE
WALLS OF POWER.
IF THEY ARE GOING TO GIVE SOCCER
GAMES AND GOING TO YOUR HOME,
THEY ARE SAYING THEY CAN'T
THEY ARE SAYING THEY CAN'T     C
THEY ARE SAYING THEY CAN'T     N
THEY ARE SAYING THEY CAN'T     T
THEY ARE SAYING THEY CAN'T     L
THEY ARE SAYING THEY CAN'T     K
THEY ARE SAYING THEY CAN'T     T
THEY ARE SAYING THEY CAN'T     O
YOU ARE BY DEFINITION
ENCOURAGING -- FIRST OF ALL YOUR
CLOSING OUT ANY POSSIBILITY OF
AGREEMENT OR COMPROMISE, AND YOU
ARE BASICALLY SAYING, HURT THEM.
HONESTLY, I BEING SINCERE.
IF YOU THOUGHT THAT NAZIS WORK
TAKING OVER THE COUNTRY, I WOULD
CONSIDER FORCE.
BECAUSE BY DEFINITION IT
ENCOURAGES VIOLENCE.
>> LETS UNDERSTAND THAT DURING
THE OBAMA ADMINISTRATION HE WAS
ACCUSED OF BEING EVERYTHING FROM
A MUSLIM SLEEPER CELL TO A
NON-AMERICAN CITIZEN.
JOE WILDS YELLED OUT, YOU LIED
TO COME UP DURING THE
PRESIDENTIAL ADDRESS.
SOMEBODY HAS TO FIX THE ISSUE.
ADMINISTRATION THAT REFUSES TO
THE AMERICAN PEOPLE AND IT'S
THEY SPEAK A LOT AND THAT'S NOT
REALLY THE ISSUE.
THE ISSUE IS, YOU HAVE A RIGHT
TO TAKE POLITICAL DIFFERENCES
AND TURN THEM INTO SOME KIND OF
MOB RETALIATION.
MAYBE THE LEFT SHOULD STOP
CALLING PEOPLE NAZIS.
MAYBE THAT'S TOO FAR.
MAYBE THAT'S SETTING THE TABLE
FOR SOMETHING AWFUL.
CAN WE AGREE ON THAT?
SUPPORT CHARLOTTESVILLE WHO HAS
NAZI WALKING AROUND WITH
SWASTIKAS?
>> IT'S ONE THING TO SAY, OF
SOMEONE WHO IS ESPOUSING, I
GUESS, NAZI VIEWS, YOU ARE A
NAZI.
BUT WHAT YOU ARE SAYING IS, WHAT
I NEED TO DO IS DESTROY YOU.
AND THAT'S WITH THE LEFT IS
SAYING, ISN'T IT?
>> I THINK WHAT HAPPENS IS, WHEN
YOU DO NOT CONDEMN, WE DO NOT
CONDEMN PEOPLE LIKE DAVID DUKE.
WE GET IT SHE'S CONFUSED WITH
THEM.
PEOPLE IN HEAVEN AT TOWN HALL
WHERE YOU SPEAK WITH PEOPLE AND